next week we'll bring a new year and a
new decade how about that and with it
some new trends and travel from trips
that are shorter to destinations off the
usual tourist itineraries vacation
planning is moving in a whole new
direction we're here to talk about it is
travel consultant francesca page of
missed travel guru.com francesca welcome
thanks for having me on absolutely you
always reg news you first come to tell
us that 29 meet 2019 was just a
record-breaking year in terms of airfare
what can we be looking forward to in
2020 right well according to the flight
tracking app hopper which tracks your
flights and tells you when to book them
we're going to see flights being very
low going into 2020 in fact they're
going to be the lowest they've been in
January since 2013 with round-trip
flights averaging domestically at one
hundred and ninety five dollars plane
about air travel so much but it is
cheaper than ever there's no question
about it and easier to get to places and
when we were here last time you talked
about this over tourism one way to maybe
combat that is the airport riot you're
using what does that mean for me right
well a great example is Ontario
International Airport it for the second
year running has been ranked as the
number one fastest growing airport in
the u.s. it's located 35 miles east of
downtown Los Angeles
so really great alternative for people
flying into Southern California you know
you're gonna save yourself time stress
and traffic too so that's definitely one
of the things we're gonna see rising
smaller airports that are near buildings
and [ __ ] I tell you is a great place if
you want to boil it really can be let's
talk about micro occasions what are what
are mic rotations mic rotations are
smaller trips people don't have as much
vacation time and also it's it's been
said to be better for your health you
can be more spontaneous there's a bunch
of benefits you don't have to deal with
jet lag so I think people are gonna be
taking more small trips throughout the
year periodically rather than one large
trip and that means looking for
last-minute deals for the you definitely
can look for last-minute deals for those
yeah and solo trip you know I was a
backpacker all by myself when I was a
kid so more people in generally do
yes they are well according to a survey
done by Expedia recently they found that
over 50% of solo travelers are looking
for trips where they can explore a city
and meet new people Los Angeles is a
really great city where you can do
really so many different things they've
got beautiful beaches you've got a great
dining scene they have this new this new
event that goes on twice a year which is
dying la it allows a traveler or even a
solo traveler to explore the city by
going to these different restaurants in
a budget-friendly way la is downtown is
improved dramatically so different so
different one of the places you
mentioned Nantucket as a historical
place that people can go and really
brings a lot I'm mad now I was gonna go
there for a mini honeymoon after
anything
Wow yeah yeah untuk it's wonderful I've
been going there for years and it's
great because it's so rich in culture
and history and those are trends we will
see in 2020 you've got the whaling
museum there the Cisco brewery which is
really fun and all these wonderful
artisanal shops up and down cobbled Main
Street - and just briefly recovered
vacation places that have recovered
disasters yes well you've got places
like Hawaii where they've got new roads
after all the landslides and flooding
new roads and bridges and lots of these
resorts and spas that you can now access
way more easily - so look for those
places the Contra disasters they I need
help from it absolutely Francesca Paige
thank you a pleasure as anyway
you